when economists refer to inflation today
they are referring to a general increase
in the level of prices of goods and
services so they're really talking about
price inflation the reason why i stress
that is because sometimes especially
when the term inflation first came into
usage it actually was referring to
monetary inflation or increase in the
money supply
so it was referring to an increase in
the money supply these two ideas are
closely related but it's important to
realize that people really are measuring
inflation they're talking when they're
talking about inflation today they're
talking about price inflation because
although these two things are related
they aren't always exactly the same
thing
it is generally true that if the money
supply and the money supply is more than
just the amount of dollars that are
printed it's the amount of dollars that
are printed it's affected by the amount
of lending that's occurring it's amount
it's affected by the number of
transactions that are occurring in the
economy and if that money supply that's
affected by all of those things grows
faster than the total real productivity
of the economy then it will generally
increase the level of prices but
especially in the short term there could
be other causes of price inflation you
could have things like supply shocks and
a supply shock is
the supply of something becomes scarce
all of a sudden and the most typical
example of a supply shock is
especially in the oil crises in the
1970s
if for whatever reason oil becomes
scarce in a country like the united
states then the price of oil and gas
would go up oil and gas would go up but
then these are inputs into a whole set
of things even that banana that you buy
at the grocery store if the price of oil
or gas or both of them frankly or the
price of oil were to shoot up even the
price of your banana would shoot up
because to get that banana to your store
you need to use some gasoline in fact a
significant fraction of that banana in
that store was probably the cost of the
gasoline for that ship to take that to
take that banana from wherever it was
grown to your grocery store and then on
a railroad and then on a truck or
whatever so this would affect the
general prices not just the prices of
oil or gas so these two things are
related but it's important to realize
that mo that people are referring to
price inflation
and the general consensus is a little
bit of it is a good thing so a little is
good a little and i want to stress
little is good and we're talking one two
maybe three percent per year and but
anything larger than that gets a little
scary because it can kind of snowball on
itself and we'll talk about that in
future videos when we talk about
hyperinflation and economists are also
afraid if inflation were to ever get
negative that leads to deflation and
we'll talk in future videos why in many
circles that is viewed as a as a scary
thing now in the united states this
inflation is measured with the consumer
price index
c
p i you'll always hear this reported in
the news especially if you watch some of
the the business programming
and there are actually multiple consumer
price indices the one that people report
whenever they say the cpi went up two
percent they're actually
they're actually referring to the cpi
dash u and the u here stands for urban
urban consumers and the reason why this
is the headline cp cpi or the one that
people actually report is because most
of the country in the united states they
are urban consumers so this is the cpi
that affects the largest number of
people's pocketbooks and the way that
it's the way that it's calculated is
it's like the deflator it's a price
index and like the deflate or it's
measuring a general increase or a
general change in the level of prices
but they actually are calculated in
slightly different ways although they
should come into agreement if they
really are met or they should be close
to each other if they really are indices
for measuring the general level of
prices but the way that the cpi works is
that they take a basket of good for this
type of consumer in a base year
so they'll pick a base year and let's
take a super simple example a
ridiculously simple example of let's say
in our little country the consumer the
urban consumer so we'll focus on cpi-u
only consumes two things in the next
video we'll see that in reality we
consume any more than two things but the
two things and they spend 60 percent of
their money on apples
on apples and they spend 40 percent of
their money on
bananas
bananas and in that base year we just
set that base price of apples at 100 and
at bananas are 100. now we're not saying
that apples and bananas cost the same
thing we're saying that we're spending
60 percent of our money on apples 40 on
bananas in that base year
and that this is just that base year
level of prices what will matter is how
much this grew what will this index
change as we go to whatever year we want
to calculate the inflation in relative
to this base year so let's say in our
current year could be the very next year
so let's say in our current year
and we're going to assume these same
weights that we're still spending
percent on apples and forty percent on
bananas in our current year the apple
index let's say that it has grown it has
grown fifty percent to one hundred and
fifty so it is plus
fifty percent and let's say that the
banana index has grown to 180. so
bananas have gotten even more expensive
plus 80 percent so how would we measure
what would we say how much would we say
the cpi-u has grown well we would take
an awaited average of these indices or
you could say a weighted average of the
growth and you could do it either way so
let's do it either way to get you the
same result so in this year our base
index is 0.6 times 100 0.6 times 100
plus 0.4 times 100 plus 0.4 times 100
and this will just come out to 100 this
is 60 plus 40 this is equal to 100 as it
should that is our base year that is our
base for our index
now over here in our current year
so this is what we're transitioning to
there's a couple of ways to do it you
could say look we're spending 60
on something that has gone up to 150 now
so we'd say 0.6
times
times 105
and then we'll say plus 0.4 times
and that gets us to let me get my
calculator out
so this gets us 0.6
times
plus
plus 0.4
times 180
so that gets us to 162.
162.
so our general if you look at this
basket this is an overly simplified
basket we have increased we have
increased from 100
from 100 to 162 or you could say this is
plus 62 percent and you would have
gotten the same result if you took the
weighted average of the percentages if
you took point six times fifty percent
plus point four times eighty percent in
fact we could do that in our head point
six times fifty percent is going to be
thirty percent and then point four times
eighty percent is going to be thirty two
percent thirty plus thirty two gives us
62 percent growth it for this basket of
goods which we're assuming is i guess
for this urban consumer from our base
year to the current year now in the next
video we'll actually look at what the
basket of goods actually looks like in
the united states
for an actual urban consumer